[Music]
hello California and everyone this is
Greg Alba
and I am Kat Alvarado is here with me
today she is a great friend of mine
lovely comedian speaking of comedian you
should go check out her website Kat
Alvarado calm there's a calendar event
section that you can keep constantly
updated on on where Kat will be
performing when and where I've seen her
live a couple times that's how I met her
it's fun she was like hey who are you
I like your laugh in the audience and
I'm like I'm Greg I have a youtube
channel she's like can I come on and I
said maybe what are you willing to do
and she said to hang out are as good I
don't know that's how I remember it is
more like he was like you're really
funny will you please come on my show
and I was like let me think about it
come on man doesn't be male demographic
we have from childhood cool speaking of
cool trump and kim jongwan a bad lip
reading of the Trump Kim summit
you know last time Kat was here we did a
reaction to a video that we talked about
some controversial stuff so I want to
make sure we avoided that completely
we're gonna do the Trump Kim summit bad
lip reading because Kat does not follow
politics at all I should know I'm
friends there on Facebook she's never
opinionated and that's why you gotta
love her a line from OHS okay today hey
but my shoes really are funny they are
funny seriously that's why I asked her
to come on in a desperate attempt put on
the headphones Kat Alvarado
I touch you yeah yeah buddy
Sabine's huh me that's pretty weird but
cool can I just say I think she's hot
just look at that thing you
she is pretty cricket dude she is
cricket I always try to be charming cuz
you never know yet dude like whatever
text me
I've read a lot of pages of his diary
and they're gonna tell you it's really
funny
he truly still wants to grow up and get
in a real rocket ship on one page he
mentioned that he was gonna Chuck a flip
phone at me and he also mentioned that
he wants a little German sheep and he
intends to name it Glenn Wow look at the
sea
I think I should have hit the nevermind
[Music]
tiny zucchini snuff for the birds
that is the Dove the devil Ishmael the
bird of one Sun whatever I'm done
drinking a milk I'm done that's it
Ishmael it's really cool we are going to
have fruit Adam it's funny about that
bad lip reading a lot of times what they
do will actually carry on a conversation
that looks like they're actually really
talking about this thing that they're
dubbing over that's what I love about
the bat liberating this time around it
who's just was a read sentences they
kept going back and forth yet you're
like but that's walking around like he
needs to hold it up poop poop poop that
was more than the fart that was like I'm
holding in them mmm I mean white women
no food I kind of missed some of the
news in the past few California right oh
yeah because when I was lost paying
attention to the news on this situation
I remember they weren't getting along
and then I saw yeah who
pitcher is like oh they're getting along
they're next to each other what no I
didn't read up on it cuz I'm a terrible
American so what happened was kim
jeong-hoon one bomb america self was
like hey rocket man you little dork
don't do it and kim jongwan was like
yeah
do it and then all his rockets like
broke like the mountain collapsed on the
Rockets and so kim giman was like yeah
totally still gonna bomb you guys and
then Trump was like yeah let's have a
summit and so then they had a summit and
then they agreed that kim jungeun
wouldn't bomb America but Loki I'm
pretty sure all his Rockets just
collapsed under mountains oh oh that's
what happened now you know wow wow wow
wow wow wow so this is good this is good
like we might not die now I mean of that
because we're a second it looked like
Trump was definitely gonna get his
killed
yeah yeah it was right well that was
unexpected I was coming to a place of
peace in my life and then this happened
and now I'm back to the stresses of
social anxiety right it was nice to kind
of just like worry about getting Newt
yeah we're all in unison well guys bad
lip reading thanks for making a more
lighthearted version of that for us that
was pretty accurate I also love their
portrayal of Kim Jong Un's just like a
little boy unexpectedly he's magically
got the present arrived and he was like
he looks like he doesn't care whenever
Trump's talking he's doing the polite
smile the whole time yeah crazy i
weirdly felt sorry for kim jongmin in
this moment if you're a proud American
you should subscribe to the real rejects
we know what we're talking about America
click that notification about the
subscribe buttons are broken patreon
exists Kat Alvarado is a talented human
being I'm not gonna say woman anymore
oh I appreciate that's wrong I mean all
you a woman as long as you don't assume
my gender but if I tell you my gender
which is female you can call me a woman
right and that's okay you just got a
like double check that's Ken Alvarado is
not a woman but a human I am cuz women
in humans are - totally check out her
website you go to my shows there's a
calendar on there I'll be there one of
these days again I've been to three yes
you've been - none of mind okay you
don't have shows July 7 6 p.m. segue